[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am Ramsey personality
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with my
good friend and bestselling author
Ramsey personality Dr John deloney and
we're here to answer your questions it's
free call anywhere in the country at8
8255 225 so call in and we'll chat about
what's going on in your life so first up
we have Tiffany in Vancouver hey Tiffany
welcome to the
show hi thank you absolutely how can we
help um so I I have a question for Dr
John I've been listening to the show up
to his podcast lately and and just
really finding his advice and and
questions uh helpful and so I so my
husband struggles with some mental
illness um and that obviously impacts
our marriage um we've been married for
about 20 years and he suffers with
bipolar depression and
anxiety um the first 10 years were
pretty rough cuz he was just kind of
being diagnosed and trying to find the
right medication and treatment and all
of those things um but there there's
been an improvement and continues to
Improvement um but I'm kind of just
getting to the point of really feeling
the impact of it on our marriage even
more so because
I'm in a not I don't want to say a
better place but like in a place where
I'm realizing kind of what's important
to me um so some like some of the ways
that it impacts is like I'm very
outgoing I'm social I like you know
traveling and doing different things uh
he does not like he he doesn't really
leave um our house a lot um he doesn't
do really enjoy socializing he does go
to like the important events that we
have which I really appreciate that he
pushes himself to do that because I know
he doesn't enjoy it and he kind of
struggles to be there um but I guess I'm
I'm struggling with feeling disappointed
and resentment even though I know it's
not him that's doing that it's it's the
mental illness but just kind of trying
to figure out what's next almost like I
I can still do the things that I want to
but I want to be able to do them with
him and so struggling how to work
through that yeah I mean it sounds like
you had a picture of what your life is
going to look like and and for 10 years
of it you were treading water and you're
or you're bailing water out of a boat
with holes in it and then you got the
the a new boat right you figured out you
got the meds regulated and sounds like
he's worked his butt off and you have
two and now you're kind of realizing oh
this is this is it yeah this is this is
as good as it's going to get well I I I
don't like to say that kind of that
language because you're going you look
at him and you keep saying he's got to
grow but you do too but but this is what
it is right now right and you see the
trajectory of where you come and you see
that you can uh you know imagine a
trajectory of where you're going
um like my hard question for you
is I don't say almost always but in a
significant number of time of of
conversations like this you've met
someone somebody and maybe you haven't
like cheated on anybody or anything like
that but you've met somebody that laughs
at your jokes tells you that you're
beautiful is hilarious shows up seems a
little more stable is that the case
here no okay so you're just looking at
this saying I love this man but I really
don't love my
life yes okay so what's your question
well because I wanna I wanna well I
wanna I guess I I don't know if there's
a like is there a way or do you have any
suggestions of like how
is this something that you can move past
like feeling frustrated and disappointed
that I don't get to enjoy these things
with him because I want to enjoy I want
to I want to travel with him and I can
still
travel yeah I I mean there's no way to
get him to travel because he's too
anxious well there's some truth to that
and also I've have people that I love
dearly that I've been in relationship
with for years that have worked really
hard and um I I've sit on the show so I
don't mind saying that my mom wouldn't
fly my mom would not get on air she I
mean it was a it was an act of Congress
to get on an airplane and in her 40s 30s
20s 30s 40s she just wouldn't do it and
she just finished her she's in her
mid-70s and she just finished her last
summer at
Oxford and so she kept working at it and
kept working at it and then started
doing it more and more and it was a work
obligation and then it was a hey I'll do
it for Dad and then a hey I want to do
this for me and then it became an idea
like dude she's been in Wales she's been
all over the world now and so that's why
I don't like to just cash it out um the
bigger deal is this so I love love love
punk rock shows and I had this picture
that my wife would always be this
tattooed up person with me that would go
to these punk rock shows if you've ever
met my wife she's not she is not that
Rachel's laughing so um Sheila could
rock some tattoos so she if she needed
to she yeah she definitely can do
tattoos but but here's the deal I had to
make peace with that's not going to
happen that's not who I
married and she to go sit on the front
row of George Straight with me but um I
want to go so so I've got a group of
buddies that I do that with in my heart
of hearts would I love that yes if
there's a show that I really want her to
come to will she do it yeah she will um
but I've made peace with it and here's
the deal I have a blast I have a blast
it's when I'm not sitting there having
the time of my life with three or four
of my close buddies with Pete and Blake
and some of these guys that I'm not
going God I wish you I wish my wife was
here cuz then I'm choosing to bring
misery into a joyful moment right so
yeah man I wish wish she would travel
wish she would do this stuff let's keep
working on it and especially if you're
if you're not saying hey I've got
somebody else I don't want this thing to
be over and also Tiffany I and I don't
want to interrupt you but I'm like I
even think what you're saying Tiffany is
that there's kind of disappointment even
even in the day-to-day like maybe not
the big fun exciting parts of life that
he doesn't want to do but even the
day-to-day kind of sounds miserable for
you so I'm like even starting off at
that level of saying gosh what what are
things we can bring into our lives that
we both find joy in to get joy back it
just feels like it's completely kind of
stripped from you in your marriage in
general is that fair yeah yeah I would
say that's accurate and the only the
only way to heal from anxiety is to walk
right through it and so sometimes there
is a survival it sounds like y'all were
surviving for a decade right which is
very common with someone who's
struggling with bipolar and people don't
people around him don't know right and
no one knows but okay now you know what
it is and instead of saying you need to
get up and do this or we need to go out
on it would really
um I would really feel loved if in two
weeks you could put on your calendar
that you go out on a date with
me and give him some time to practice
give him some time to think through it
give him some time to be anxious about
it and then yall practice leaning into
it cuz does he want to continue to push
to get better to Tiffany or are you
wanting this more for
him like is he wanting it he does yeah
he he does want it I think I yeah I
think sometimes like the an the anxiety
and the depression squash the the desire
yeah it just gets heavy gets exhausting
gets exhausting yeah um and then some
nights he's going to get up and go out
even though his body says hey dude let's
get under the covers and just watch
another Netflix series and yeah some
nights you're going to want to go out
and you're going to sit down and hold
his hand and let him borrow some of your
nervous system and yall are going to
watch a show together and that this is
marriage but this is also y'all are
continuing to practice and practice and
practice and then dude it would not
surprise me at all if he is um begins to
find enjoy and you'll get further and
further connected I'm going to ask you
don't continue to drag the well I wish
and uh could be into a world where
that's not possible I'm going to ask you
to bring posit like positivity but not
just positivity optimism about here's
where I am I really want to go to this
concert I'm going to go do this I want
to go on this trip I'm going to invite
some girlfriends it doesn't mean my
marriage is broken it means I wanted it
to be like this but I'm going to do it
like this and keep walking alongside him
I think y'all can get there I think you
can get there thank you Tiffany for
calling this is the ramsy show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different soft software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of ramsy we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we use to optimize and take
us to the next level netsuite gave us
the visibility into all of our numbers
so that we could communicate across
departments and plan ahead better and as
we grew it scaled with with us net week
worked for ramsy and it will make a
difference for your business too join
the more than 34,000 customers who trust
netsuite to help make them smarter and
make better decisions and level up their
operations to learn more get a free
product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Dr
John deloney answering your questions up
next we have John in New York City hey
or Jason sorryy hey Jason welcome to the
show hey thank you thank you big fan of
the show guys thank you for having me oh
thanks for calling in we appreciate it
how can we help yeah so I uh retired
from the Army 20 years active duty and
um I've been retired for like five years
now and just again I set that set where
I'm at I make about 150,000 a year now
with my retirement uh the only debt I
have is my car payment I have a rather
expensive car that I should not have
bought during covid it's a 2022 AC RDX
that I have 49,000 on um I know it's
probably only get about 37,000 out of it
if I tried to trade it in or or sell it
somewhere around there uh from what I
from what I've already found out um I
don't have any credit card debt I don't
own a house I'm renting right now um I
just married last year I'm just trying
to get on track and I have the Thousand
doll put away but my problem is I have
$155,000 in
cryptocurrency and I know
with me please um I bought in you know
whenever it was all the hype and I had
19,000 but it's down to 15,000 yeah so
I'm I'm in the negative for 4,000 on it
if I were to sell it right now yeah and
my question to you guys is what would
you recommend I've actually listened to
a lot of your like a lot of your
episodes and I'm just one of those weird
situations where do I pay off my car
take all my extra money and pay off my
car do I sell the car and get something
cheaper do I sell my Bitcoin like I'm
I'm up you know up for some advice from
you guys yes oh my gosh okay do you have
any other money saved just the not
non-retirement
um yeah yeah I have about six or seven
I'm close to 7,000 this be 7,000 in in a
liquid account okay good for
you
um man okay I'm GNA tell you so I'll
I'll tell you what I would do but you're
probably not going to like it Jason no
it's fine I want to hear I feel like the
because what we do on show I think the
best is to help people get from point A
to point B when it comes to Building
Wealth and so you have a lot of pieces
to these puzzles to this puzzle and I
think if you choose to put them in
correctly it's going to be a really
beautiful picture it's probably going to
look a little different than your life
right now in a sense uh but it's it's
what I would do so I would take the hit
on the car I'd sell it uh and then I
would take your 15,000 because you're
going to you're still going to owe some
uh because you're underwater on it and I
would Cash Out Bitcoin use that 15 grand
for that difference and you'll have
about three left out of the Bitcoin I
would go and buy a car with maybe six
grand take three there take three out of
the 7,000 that you have be completely
debt free start building up my emergency
fund with $4,000 that I have left over
and continue on my way I would take I
would personally just go ahead and take
the loss on the Bitcoin because even
though it hurts honestly there's no
great track record that shows you're not
going to continue to lose money you may
we may look up a year and and if history
serves me right it's probably going to
be even worse so I would take it out now
and let your pay the quote unquote
stupid tax of losing the four grand in
Bitcoin that's what we always call is a
stupid tax when you do something you
lose money you're just like Dad G it but
I'm never going to do that again take
the loss and then see that 15 grand as
as I mean this is key I'm like this is a
really this is a this is a gift at that
point to go ahead and you know take the
loss of the car get rid of the car
payment completely uh the car loan and
continue on my way is what I would do
but again that that puzzle that we just
put together that picture that final
picture looks different than you sitting
with a nice what was it an Audi an Acura
uh sitting with a nice car and some cash
over here you know and this and some
Bitcoin over here it's it's taken all
that down to a life with no debt with a
crappier car but some savings and then
continuing to move forward from there
yeah and I I that's what I was wondering
I knew I would take a large hit on the
car and I knew I'd take a large hit on
the on the Bitcoin it would put me you
know somewhat in the ne at least in the
positive but then I'll be starting fresh
with another car and I have been looking
at cars really cheap it's just I didn't
know what you guys recommended on that
because I've been looking at cars around
you know 7 to 10,000 and it's like they
have 100,000 miles right well I know and
with my worry now yeah and when we look
at cars in general if it's more than
half of your annual ual take-home pay
that's always a red flag or if you can't
pay it off in 12 to 18 months so maybe
you say yeah if we buckle down and
finish paying this off but gosh you
still have $49,000 left on
it yeah yeah so I mean if you guys want
to but New York City it's going to be
hard to I mean just the standard of
living that you guys are in naturally
it's it it'll it'll you'll feel that
you'll feel that pinch uh if you're
going to try to sacrifice and just pay
it off I almost would just get rid of it
Jason honestly yeah so let me ask you
this Jason what would the number be so
you're you're a combat veteran you've
been active duty um what is the number
if I said hey for
$10,000 not one person on planet Earth
will own you
Jason you can do whatever you want you
can go to work if you want to or not to
you can sleep you and your wife can just
go your new wife y'all can go vacation
you like nobody can tell you what to do
what would that number be man
gosh that's a really great question I
don't know if there is a is as a number
I could put on it so um here here's
here's here's the other side so you're
looking at the loss and psychologically
speaking our brains are designed to look
for loss that's why somebody can like
500 people in an audience can say Jason
that was the greatest speech of all time
and one guy will go eh that sucked and
you won't sleep at night cuz that one
guy right that's all of us that's our
brains are wired you're only seeing I
lost 4,000 here I lost the acur here I'm
smart and I did something stupid I'm
dumb right all that's all you're seeing
I want you to flip it around on the
other
side Acura Financial I don't know how
where you finance that car from they
USAA you whoever it is they
demand that you go to work tomorrow
because you owe them they are your
boss if your boss is say hey you're
going to start selling this product
you're like I don't believe in that
product your boss going to go yeah I
don't really care uh you're going to do
this or you're fired and then your brain
sets off the little alarms cuz it knows
oh dude we can't live here we're going
to take the car we're going to lose this
we're going to lose this and so for me
$44,000 of loss plus 10,000 on the car
15 grand for my soul dude I'll pay that
all day long yeah I'll pay that all day
long and so you're already married you
already are one of the toughest bravest
men on planet Earth you've dedicated
your life to public service and courage
you have nothing left to prove to
anybody get an $88,000 car with 100,000
miles who cares you already found
somebody that says I do forever right
You've Won You've Won you're there you
have nothing to prove to nobody man go
go choose Freedom that's what I'm saying
yeah I know and and honestly for me
Jason the car conversation it is hard
because if it's like a student loan you
got to pay it right I mean like there's
no getting around it there's no selling
something the car it's such like an and
I'm not saying this is you Jason just
our culture it's such an ego play of
like this is a nice car and I you know
it's there's like a there's a part of
all of us that our identity is so
attached to our stuff and that's what it
is I'm like not to mention hey I I slept
in like on 2x4s right on on plywood as
active duty i' I deserve an accurate and
as somebody whose family benefits from
your service I agree yes I hope that you
youur again you solve for freedom and
you get whatever car you want you save
it up and buy it with cash um and buy it
from some knucklehead in your same
position who's underwater and who's
going to have to get rid of it right so
I just want you to be able to afford it
cuz I not only do I want you to have a
nice car because I do think you you
deserve it more than more than most I
want you to sleep all
night and absolutely I want you to have
deep connected intimate moments with
your wife and have not that little part
of your brain going we're not safe we're
not safe Acura owns us like I don't want
that I want you to be able to just plug
in and do whatever you want to see what
I'm saying yeah that's why I call this
what I this what I needed to hear I've
been trying to get old you guys for a
while so I'm glad I actually got through
totally go be free free man and not to
go and like jump in the numbers but
again I just want to I want to reiterate
Jason like that 7,000 because you
already have your thousand saved up it
could take the car Alan down to 42 and
according to our standard math here at
Rams that we do you could choose to
sacrifice a lifestyle of a year or
something and pay it off and do what you
can but is all of that worth it for the
car right the car would continue to go
down in value yes oh yeah and it that's
true yes it continues to go down so for
me I'm like it's not it's not worth the
sacrifice for the car like just get rid
of the car and we're going to move on
and have freedom like what John's
explaining so I'm so glad Jason that you
got through and we were able to talk to
you we hope that that helps I'm grateful
for you brother yep oh thanks for your
service for sure this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free
see why blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to save up to
40% off everything sitewide go to
blinds.com for more
[Music]
information
welcome back to the ramsy show we're
taking your calls it's a free call
anywhere in the country at
88255 225 the Ramsay show question of
the day is brought to you by neighborly
your hub for Home Services neighborly is
one place that brings together a
nationwide family of locally operated or
operators
gosh operated providers to help I can
never read these out take I got you I
got you neighborly I got you take care
of your repairs routine M maintenance
and Home Improvements go to neighborly
docomo to start your search I up at 4
a.m I'm G to blame that I go you can
probably go to neighbor.com to get
lessons on how to read too just go to
neighbor.com all right today's question
comes from Annie in Florida my husband
are two kids and I live with my husband
USB's widowed mom who doesn't work we
pay all the bills buy Grocery and pay
her house taxes she and I don't get
along 90% of the time especially when it
comes to my kids my husband and I are
not on the same page with money and I
don't have control over the money unless
he gives it to me we have one debt left
and we could pay it off in one to two
months if we work together but there's
just no urgency from him my sanity is on
the brink and I'm tired of arguing with
my husband and being run over by my
in-laws I've talked to my husband and
tried to lay bound boundaries but then
I'm just a control freak quote unquote
according to my
mother-in-law sometimes I just want to
leave and get my own apartment with my
kids but I don't feel like that would be
right and would make things worse I know
I shouldn't let other people control my
emotions but this is like a wound that
keeps getting cut open and salt poured
in it is getting away from my
mother-in-law going to fix things or am
I the
issue good night well I don't like that
she can't get money unless he gives it
to me no thank you I'm a control freak
according to my mother-in-law no thank
you yeah it sounds like you are just
breathing the air of Planet Gaslight
yeah so I all we can go on Annie is what
you've written here and so here's what I
would tell you um based on exactly what
you wrote and I always want to hold in
both hands there there's there's two
sides to a story you are not the issue
yes getting away from your mother-in-law
would fix some things but the bigger
thing here is you have a husband who
is over over overbearing does not have a
partner um he is much more interested in
making sure his mommy's okay and um his
mommy's brought into all of your life
then he is being married and building a
life with you co-creating a world with
his wife so yes getting away from your
mother-in-law would for sure help and
you got to deal with your marriage got
to deal with your marriage and it sounds
like your husband has very little
interest in dealing with your marriage
and in fact when you try he um turns it
over to his mom and she lobs grenades at
you so
um Rachel there's there's this idea that
we're going to take
a for lack of better terms we're going
to we're going to take a practice
separation for a few days and it might
be up to 30 days it might be for two
weeks but it is a I'm choosing to step
out because I'm not I'm becoming
somebody that I don't want to be with my
kids I'm becoming somebody I don't be
with you right and anytime you do that
it's important to have we're going to
circle back at this time at this date at
this restaurant to talk um we're going
to bring this person with us you got to
set some guide rules but this is one of
those moments that continuing just to
stay in this sewer um somebody's going
to end up doing something that you can't
take back yep and so Annie you're not
crazy um you are not messed up here um
it sounds like you have tried to do
what's right and you are just getting
dragged underw I think that's one of the
hardest parts of marriage when you hear
a situation like that because for so
many people I think learning to balance
how do I take care of myself but also
take care of this relationship this
lifelong relationship that I'm in right
right but taking care of yourself is the
key to then having a healthier marriage
and I think sometimes we mix those up
and think I got to just fix my marriage
fix my marriage but it's actually
getting you making sure you're okay
taking care of yourself in these moments
right especially well especially if this
sounds a this almost sounds like this is
not good I was going to say abusive but
anytime somebody gives their wife an
allowance yeah that to me I classify
that is abusive that is controlling
nonsense Behavior right for two adults
for two adults right but often in this
situation and it's usually wife playing
trying to please husband right not
always but often it is the way I'm going
to try to fix my marriage is by cutting
off parts of me yes so that I can make
this this thing that we're quot unquote
doing together all right and what often
people find after they've cut all their
toes off and all their fingers off and
is that oh he's just going to keep
moving he doesn't change it yeah he's
going to keep moving the Finish Line it
was never about us healing our marriage
right it was never about me healing and
him healing and us making this new thing
it was about he's just going to keep
doing whatever he wants to do right and
you find yourself with nothing right so
that's why I like someone to step out
and the the language I use is somebody's
got to turn on the lights turn off the
music the part's over I'm going to step
out I'm going to move into this place
with my girlfriend I'm going to move
into this place with my mother-in-law I
mean with my mother and the kids what do
you I'd bring him if you can and often
you learn a lot if he doesn't fight you
on it then that tells you what you need
to know right but me and the kids we
going to move over here for a couple of
weeks and I got to breathe because I
can't have your mother-in-law doing this
I can't have you blaming me for all this
and if he goes I'm about to lose my
marriage and he gets a quick dose of
reality then that's beautiful if he goes
fine get out of here me and my mom are
that's ex he's really telling you what
you need know y right yep oh so hard
Annie thanks for I hate this for you I
hate this I hate this this I I don't
have a psychology and I'm this is a bias
and I know it happens all over the place
I don't have a world and where if I sat
down with my wife and I said hey I need
this that her first response would be
sucks to be you but I just don't live in
that world right and so these things
break my heart that's right right like
hey I need you to to help with I'm not
doing that man that's tough that's tough
tough tough tough that's so hard so so
hard all right let's go back to the
phones we have uh Braden in Memphis
Tennessee hey bradden welcome to the
show hey Rachel how John hey John how's
it going we're doing great how can we
help um so I'm getting ready to lock in
my rate I'm building a house and um my
banker got in touch with me and I know
that y'all always said to go with a
15-year fixed but on the 30 year I got
quoted at a
6.6 and on a 15 year I got quoted at a
7.25 and I didn't know if that has
anything to do with y'all's
decision yeah the decision is less about
interest rate and more about just
urgency of getting it paid off and that
when you have a 15-year you're obviously
naturally going to pay it off half of
the time that you would in a 30-year but
also with the plan that we encourage
people to pay off their house even
sooner than that than the 15 years so
that's that's why that principled rule
is in place when it comes to mortgages
it's really less about the interest rate
which is so interesting because usually
it's flipped it's almost never like is
is it an adjustable rate she said this
she said this is the first time she's
seen it do that they're both fixed right
a 30-y year and a 15year fix um I wasn't
really worried about it and was leaning
towards going with the 30-year just
because my last house I paid off in
seven months and 20 days and so um you
know I'm pretty intentional on it but
I'm definitely not planning on doing
that with this one just because that
last one like have killed
me uh yeah where where are you guys
Braden financially I'm just curious you
guys out of debt and have savings your
building and all that zero debt um I've
got 35,000 set aside for an emergency
fund and um the house of praise to be
worth like
89900 yeah that's amazing congrats what
have you run the math on it just to see
it it this interest rate if I paid it
off in 15 versus that interest rate if I
paid it off in
15 um or I paid it off in
30 which one will come out
ahe I I haven't Rand the math because
basically on either one I was going to
do I was planning on paying it off in no
more than probably two years because I
only B I only borrowed 80,000 on it so
it's not very much of a mortgage what do
you do for a
living I I just run my own business I I
really make a whole lot I've just uh
always done y'all's um plan since I was
probably eight but you're going to pay
off a 90 a $900,000 house in two years
well you paid most of it with cash what
you're saying you only borrowed 80
that's impressive yeah awesome well you
know we stick with the principal of that
15y year uh it doesn't matter for you
yeah at that point the interest rate
isn't even that big of a swing because
you're going to be paying it off so soon
so the principle again is to pay it off
as soon as possible Braden fantastic job
well done either either way you're not
making bad decisions in life you're
doing really good so keep up the good
[Music]
work
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Church Hill gives
you an advantage over those other guys
go to Churchill mortgage.com today to
learn
[Music]
more so one thing we say around here a
lot is that money is not a math problem
usually and most always it's a you
problem it's a me problem it's us that
are handling money that is creating uh
the stress and the buying and everything
else and so Jade warshaw one of our
Ramsey personalities just came out with
a money's not a math problem quick read
the real reason you're broke and what to
do about it so make sure to check it out
you guys it's really good so oh it's
actually it's on pre-sale for just 10
bucks and you can also access a live
online Q&A with Jade that she's going to
do but she's going to talk about the
five lies that we believe about
budgeting and really unpacking this idea
of how much our behavior is so crucial
to us winning with money so go to Ramsey
solutions.com store for that and then
our other great friend George camel
Breaking Free from broke the Ultimate
Guide to more money and less stress is
also at dve ramsey.com or also ramsy
solutions.com store and you can
pre-order that book it is coming out in
January and George does a fantastic job
being George and funny and great stories
and all the things uh really walking
through this approach of Building Wealth
and getting out of the system CU they's
such the system financially that people
get stuck in and it's like a ferris whe
just over and over and over and over and
so getting out of that and actually
winning with your money Breaking Free
from broke by George camell make sure to
pre-order that at ramseys solutions.com
we have all of your holiday shopping for
your crazy Aunt you can give them my
book 20 bucks yeah for your grandkids or
your kids you can give them your brand
new book yeah $12 for some of these yeah
change your past uh own your past change
your future you're an incredible
salesman own your whatever your book's
called John this is a uh a toyonda is it
a Toyota or a Honda it doesn't matter
it's a car it's a great own your past
changer feature $12 but you could buy um
like money is not the problem for all of
your friends and breaking be from BR
like we got you dude yep yep so make
sure to check out all that stuff you
guys some good money content we're
putting out into the world to help
people get that hope back all right
let's go to David in Colorado Springs
hey David welcome to the
show good to talk to you guys how you
doing absolutely we're great we're glad
that you called us David how can we
help okay um make a long story short um
my stepdaughter has really been into
figure skating since she's about six
years old and about a year and a half
ago she decided she wanted to start
competing so we're like well we we'll
give it e year see if she sticks with it
and she really has and she started
competing last year and is doing great
the issue is that we are kind of on the
low end of spending for this Sport and
it's costing us almost $1,000 a month oh
goodness and it just goes up from there
um having more coaching working with a
physical trainer uh starting to travel
having to pay for the coach to travel to
competitions and we're we really are
probably over our budget with what we're
spending now but at the same time she
really loves this and we're kind of
trying to figure out how do you balance
her loving the sport and us not going
broke man how old is she now she is 14
okay I I've got some unpopular opinions
on this that I always get in trouble for
can I just put them out there is that
cool John stirs the pot in all very few
things do I get in more trouble from the
internet people than this but here we go
um I would
suggest that we've grown up in a culture
we've created a culture where the kid is
the star of the family
show and ultimately where do you want to
eat what do you want to do who do you
want to become what do you want to be
when you grow up what college do you
want to go to what's your dream school
we dump all of these things in our kids
backpack think of them as rocks we just
Dro in our kids and what happens without
meaning to and this happens like us
trying to love and honor and give our
kids opportunities that we didn't have
they end up carrying the weight of the
whole
house and I dude I'm a product of sports
I played Sports all the way through I
was a two sport Letterman I ran in
college I did MMA with professionals
like I'm all about sports and teams and
workouts and discipline all that stuff's
great and the greatest gift I I can give
my kid is not mortgaging my soul and our
future and literally a second lit a
second mortgage that some people do to
pay for this stuff yeah to let them
quote unquote do whatever they want or
do whatever they're passionate about do
whatever they what feels right the
greatest gift I can give them is a
stable at peace Mom and Dad that's the
greatest gift and so before I get down a
road where I'm paying for private
coaching I got to fly the coach in or
drive the coach in now we got to do this
it it it just starts building and like
you said a little bit of success breeds
this and if you try to back out it's
like it's like a a time share salesman
right they're like hey but we see really
a bright future with your daughter and
if you do this then it could lead to
this and it could lead to this and you
your daughter's just sitting there
looking at you and you feel like you
feel like the Antichrist pulling some of
the stuff away and so I always think
it's best to not follow the rabbit down
the rabbit hole on this but it's to
start all the way at the beginning with
your wife and say hey what kind of home
do we want to have and we're going to
reverse engineer it that way and what
can we actually afford so takes ice
skating away and input
Lexus if she was really passionate about
Alexis and really a good driver and you
couldn't afford Alexis you wouldn't buy
her
Alexis but for some reason Sports have
become the altar that we sacrifice our
families on and that we allow our
families and our kids to worship and I I
I think it's beyond Madness it's gone to
pathology now um and at the same time
dude I get it I can't imagine having a
daughter who's starting to excel you're
a stepdad You're Building relationships
and connections and then you're going to
sit down and like you're going to take
this away right I get that I can't think
of something that would be harder to do
as a parent um I just am seeing family
after Family Mortgage their souls for
sports and travel Sports and the sake of
whatever my kid wants to do I'm going to
I'm going to do it and the kids can't
carry that weight we end up burying our
children what do you think David yeah
yeah it's that that's kind of my
thinking it's you know more we draw a
line in the sand and it's like yeah this
is what we can afford Y and I'm I'm
sorry Y and I and David honestly too if
you don't do that nobody else is this I
skating Community isn't going to the the
trainer's not going to the the
championship tournament places aren't
going like no one else is going to do
that you literally could spend and spend
and spend and spend and and there's
nobody in the world that's going to be
like hey David you got to stop so that's
when Da that's when you and your wife
together have to say we have to we have
to put a boundary up because there's
nobody else on planet Earth that puts up
boundaries for us we have to create
those ourselves and if you don't
especially these little microcosms of
life and kids sports is one of them them
you can just go down a train just like
John's saying and it's and you look up
and you guys have spent your retirement
I mean you've done all of this and I I
know I just it I just am so so cautious
especially and I would say this too
David even if you guys had the money it
would be an interesting conversation too
the urgency may not be there like at
like with the money there's a little bit
of a fin night we just we don't have the
money like we can't do that and we're
not going to stress ourselves out and
miss a mortgage payment for ice SK like
that's that's in like that's that's
insane we can't do that we adults she's
14 and we have to make adult mature
decisions in our household and run our
household and then what comes after that
is what we have to decide but we're not
going to put ourselves in a financial
bind for this we can't we won't and so
you draw that line but even if you had
the money I think what John's saying is
interesting and I know it's so
controversial here's the deal I've got
friends that are athletic trainers at
universities yeah and they continue to
tell me that they're bringing 18 and 19
year olds with joint overuse injuries
that they see in geriatric populations
shoulders and knees and hips that were
not designed to do the same sport yes
day after day week after week year after
year since someone was a child and all
the way up through their bodies can't
handle that right um so if there's like
a and and I I don't know David what your
options are but my encouragement would
be hopefully to be able to find a group
to plug in whether it's a wreck and not
competition I mean I don't know what it
is for ice skating but like where she
can still do what she loves right and
enjoy it but it's just not at this high
specific level that is so narrow intense
for 14 you know if this is my house
inexpensive I would sit my son down
who's 13 almost here and I'd walk him
through our budget and then I would say
here's what it costs for rent here's
what it costs for electric water all
that food what we spent and then here's
what we got for this and this is our cap
and then I'm not just going to say it in
the vacuum but I'm going to show him
here's what we can afford that's right
David thanks so much for calling and
thank you America for listening John for
always being a great co-host and all the
guys in the booth for making the show
happen this is the ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I am Ramy personality
Rachel Cruz hosting this this hour with
Ramsey personality and bestselling
author Dr John delone it's a free call
anywhere in the country at 8825
5225 all right let's start off with
Amanda in Fort Lauderdale Florida hey
Amanda are you guys getting like crazy
rain down there yeah yeah that's so
crazy hi guys good afternoon thank you
so much for taking my call yeah thanks
for calling I literally just saw that on
the news I think it was last night and
it was like you guys are like getting
flooded and stuff it's crazy oh it's
been Wild I live in Fort Lauderdale and
it it happens quite often up here
actually all the schools got canceled
but I work in Miami dat so I actually
had to travel to work today oh my gosh
be careful be safe I'm so
sorry I'm okay though I got I got
through it all the flooding wasn't too
bad getting here so okay good good good
good how can we help so um I am I am
ready to attack my student loans I have
$76,000 in stud mod unfortunately but um
I'm ready to attack them I'm a new
listener for you guys and so I'm ready
that gazelle intensity but I have a a
car Le sitting in my way and I wanted
your advice today as to kind of how to
get out of it so here's my numbers for
you guys I have the 76,000 in student
loans I have $199,000 in savings um I
have 30k and my 401k I make about $3,700
a month and I leased a Camry three years
ago it's a $28,000 car um and my lease
is up in I think about5 days actually oh
wow it's almost done okay yeah so I have
a couple options here I can I can pay
the car off with the money that I have
in my savings account but that would
pretty much put me almost down to zero
yeah um and keep the car pretty much for
the rest of its life right which is
which is gonna be the rest of your life
because Camry go on for eternity right
that's what I've heard so I was excited
about that but um then my secondary
option is to get out of that car and
just buy you know what what you guys
call a little banger just something
under 10,000 and then the rest of my
savings I go ahead and put that towards
my student loans and then keep paying
those off um what's what's the payoff
amount yeah what's the payoff it's 18K
okay how much could you sell it for do
you know if you did you Kelly Blue Book
it see its value yeah yeah it looks to
be worth from like 24 to
okay and 11k into it yeah you have 11k
into it you can buy it at 18 and you
like it
yeah I do it's a great car yeah I think
I would buy it I know there's a part of
me that would just go ahead and just do
it because it still has great Val I mean
like for what you could sell it for you
could buy yeah I almost would buy it and
then could you turn around and sell
it I could yeah I could I I guess I'd
make a little bit of money off of it and
then I can use that to help buy you know
a cheaper car y um you tell me you drive
from Fort Lauderdale to Miami day how
far does that drive every day
yeah it's about 35 miles actually I'm an
athletic trainer at high school you sh
you shouted out an AP earlier that was
awesome but I'm right hey hold on I'm
right aren't
I yeah yeah yeah so I I drive I drive
kind of far it's you know 40 45 minute
drive to work in homes about 60 70 miles
a day okay yeah I mean there's a part
yeah Amanda I'm thinking turn around and
sell it buy it out sell it you'll Bank
6K put some of your 19,000 with that and
go get a used Toyota Camry and or
whatever it may be um because you could
actually make some of that money back
which is great um but I'm also not mad
at you if you go just pay cash for this
you've driven it you love it it works
for you you'll have this car for the
next decade take care of it and okay I
wouldn't be mad at that
either okay and then just go after my
student loans with you know I'm I'm
looking into get another job um to
really supplement my income to try to
attack that 76 because I know it's a big
amount for person one weird thing that
I've heard people do when they have a
commute like you have is to
potentially do lifter Uber on the way to
work and on the way
home oh and so you're already driving
you're already driving this 30 miles and
you might get somebody to the airport
and back or you might be a be able to
leave 30 minutes early and end up not
adding a lot to your life TimeWise but
you can knock out some drives that way
yeah because you're you're making
probably is it what 36 37,000 a year is
that what you said 3500 a month I think
3,700 3700 a month my my pay is kind of
weird because I do get stiens twice a
year but I don't really count that into
my yeah salary because I don't get it
every two weeks right okay so that's
your take comp pay so yeah you're
probably about 45 annually so yeah I
would up your income though Amanda
because you're going to have to attack
this
76 um pretty aggressively so if there's
things that you can do at night whether
it's something even creative like what
John was saying with Uber um cut
Saturday and Sunday coaching I mean for
these kids who love like like uh private
uh private lessons for these kids who
are going to be NFL Stars someday or I
skating star somay I I actually am
looking into an online uh Professor job
because I have my Master's Degree so
perfect that'd be incredible that's
awesome yeah that's great so great oh
well we're excited for you am man I
think you you have the right uh Gump
in your voice I feel like we can
hear people's tone even in their call
and you can tell the people they're like
okay I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready I'm
ready I'm ready um so y that's awesome
thanks thanks for the call Amanda up
next we have Lloyd and Boise Hey Lloyd
welcome to the
show all right um so I'm calling in
because uh I'm trying to figure out the
best decision to make and basically my
wife and I were about to pay off a house
and they like 38,000 left on it and we
have enough in the bank we're just
saving to so our emergency fund doesn't
fund doesn't just tank out
basally so uh we'll have it paid off in
like two or three months something like
that it's awesome um once I get the
house paid off um I'm trying to look at
some options so my employer they will do
they have uh 401k and they have rth and
they both I can do 15 %
into um that's a lot 30% is a lot to
take out of my take-home pay yeah what
we're wanting to do is save for our next
house because I don't want to have any
more loans basically um and so I'm
thinking it'll take two or three years
to come up with 150 um
basically so I'm wanting to know kind of
should we invest like I know I want
invest in the retirement account um I
don't know if I should invest now um but
I'm wondering if I should invest into
just a mutual fund that we can then take
out two three years from now for the
house
specifically yeah for the house
specifically or if we should just put it
into savings yeah if it's going to be
that short term if you're really going
to use the money in two years I think a
good high yield savings is is a great
option just to put it for short term I
don't know if I would
put it in the market for just two years
I just feel like it's kind of volatile
with the market you really want to write
it out I mean you could do like a
Vanguard account that'd be in the S&P
like an index fund but I don't even know
if I would do that Lloyd for two years I
probably would just let it sit in a high
yield the exact thing and I'm put in
high yield yeah so that's what I mean
that's what I would do just to give you
some options you're not trying to time
the market or something weird if you
need the money and it is a dip and
you're having to kind of figure it out
it's just nice just to have the cash uh
if it was 5 years or something four or
five years we may could talk about
something different but for you guys
yeah if it's one to two years I would
just do a high yield savings to put to
save for the next house which is
exciting thanks for the
[Music]
[Applause]
call hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial peace and you don't see
any way out you need y refi they're not
a debt settlement company and they're
not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get in anywhere else
to help you stick to your budget and
work the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lump some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
Ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show uh John
this
article on well it wasn't an article it
was a dad on Reddit and and I'm going to
assume it was real I'm assuming it's
real course well it's on it's up
people.com um D rdit so oh they did okay
so they they actually like probably
confirmed that on my show we have a
segment called am I the problem right um
and so this is kind of a great am I the
problem is this me right am I the issue
here am I what's wrong here go for it uh
so a dad and his daughter are no longer
speaking after he refused to give her
thousands of dollars for her wedding
according to the post on Reddit the dad
who remains Anonymous shared that his
daughter asked him for
$200,000 to plan her dream destination
wedding in New Zealand so that's not
thousands of dollars hundreds of
thousands of dollars not tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands my
daughter is getting married and wishes
to have a destination wedding and I told
her no my wife feels like I should do it
because we can afford it but I find it
to be pointless showing off wealth now
my daughter is not speaking to me nor is
my wife oh my gosh oh my gosh which got
me thinking should I bite the bullet and
essentially burn the money and alienate
my family members to make my daughter's
Dream wedding a reality it has over
4,000 comments there on the situation on
Reddit oh man what do you think
man okay the only like 2% of me that
would be like all right come on dad as
if he was a
billionaire and it was
0.001% of you know and he's just like I
don't want to I I would not not speak to
him but I would be like come on down but
that is
0.00001% of the population that that
would even be him so I'm assuming that's
probably not him I don't think I don't
know if a billionaire would be on redit
talking about this well but but even
like so I think about like my kids and
I'm saying even if you're a billionaire
your daughter should not not speak to
you because of this either but I could
see it being frustrating I'm like Dad
you have billions of dollars but but I
could even see it the other way where
he's saying I I don't want to if if I
have a billion dollars I don't want to
flaunt my wealth in the face of my other
family members that can't afford to come
on this trip yes right can't afford to
fly to New Zealand and spend a week no
it's insane it's insane and so I dude I
am team team Dad Dad 1,000% cuz that
mean
$200,000
$200,000 and you know who the the real
villain here in this is the mom mom come
on Mom I think and
the bratty daughter could you imagine
not speaking to your dad because he
didn't give you
$200,000 that's where I'm like they have
to be somewhat level of something right
they should they have to have some level
of money for this to even he said I can
afford it it's a pointless showing of
wealth yeah this is just me waving a
flag around the world that look how rich
I am okay here I'm going to continue to
play as Devil's Advocate because we all
know the the the common sense yes
response to this is what everyone is
thinking that's insane that's insane
would it be at all understandable again
the whole not speaking thing I don't
like but would it be weird if he like
well it's his money so I guess he do it
I'm just saying like if he flaunts and
he does whatever he wants and he's like
nope not going to help not going to like
could there be frustration if he's like
I'm not going to FLT my wealth and she's
like Dad what are you kidding me look at
you you have a well you have a $200,000
watch on your wrist and you have a
whatever whatever what you know what I'm
saying like yeah I get that but it says
down here further I told her I would pay
for the one I'm not saying this is her
situation don't think it but he said I
told her I would pay for it I never
agreed to pay for destination so it
sounds like she came to and said Daddy
are you going to pay for my wedding and
he goes I love you baby you got it and
Mom was like Yay and they got together
and they're like hey let's I know what
we can do let's go to New Zealand and
okay so do you think it's a different
story if he says I'm G to give you a
$200,000 budget and she's like perfect
I'm going to take that money and go to
New Zealand for my destination wedding
at that point she can go wherever she
wants and then he says no you're not you
can't that's right yes I that's a
different story if you ask me y y and
I'm trying to figure out all the
scenarios because it's on Reddit and so
they're I'm like how many angles can we
we find out of this story you're you're
I think you're being very very generous
no I know I'm just playing Devil's
Advocate but man
yeah and he says tomorrow I'm going to
make phone calls in price of wedding in
New York it be for about 100 to 200
people oh yeah which is still going to
be 50 to 75 for 100 grand easy oh yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah no that's oh yeah for
sure for sure I just am like I guess
there are people out there that would
not speak to their dad or their parent
and their W and his wife because they
didn't get what they wanted out of it
right
like for me it just all works together
it's like if you're gonna ask for a
$200,000 destination New Zealand wedding
that's going to alienate your friends
and family and just be a way to show the
world look at my Instagram photos yes
that's probably also a family where if
you don't get your way you don't talk to
Dad and your mom goes yeah and she
doesn't talk to husband either Y and a
guy who's trying to do the right thing
and be a good Steward of his resources
and also not alienate family and friends
because everyone's going to have to buy
plane tickets to go to New Zealand
that's what that's what he says here yes
so it's not like you're paying for
everyone to go you're making them pay an
insane amount of money to come yeah lots
of principles here y'all lots of
principles here's principle number one
don't be an idiot don't be
ANP the to the daughter and the wife
don't be like I'm taking my ball and
going home come on
dude ah
well I should try that out on Dave you
should like Hey
Dad I'm not going to speak to you no I
think it'd be cool if you got him to say
like hey he's in on something hey Dave
me and Winston are like struggling can
would you help us out sure Rachel
anything okay cool here's what we're
struggling on um we're going to do
Christmas on the moon and uh it's
$400,000 and you can for sure afford it
and if you can't I'm never and if you're
not going to do that I'm I'm done I'm
done I'm done I'm done here just the way
you say it I'm done my gosh my father is
ridiculous I want to come in on a zebra
in New Zealand so sad all right Austin
maybe you can save us and put us back
into reality Austin from Kansas City
you're up next thanks for
calling hi thanks for taking my call
absolutely would you not speak to your
parents Austin if they refuse to give
you a $200,000 wedding I think I
probably would speak to them I think
that's good we're on the right track how
can we help Austin yeah so um so my
partner um is struggling with some
finances and and and we're trying our
best to get her out of it um she's about
$45,000 in student loan debt and has
about 6,000 in credit card debt um and
well we've been chipping away at it I
guess kind of and we're one I guess
wondering the best way to do that and
two she's in a career that it's kind of
uh you kind of need to go to a master's
degree for and we're wondering if if she
should just go into more debt to get the
master's degree or if she should work a
little bit first and get it peed down
yeah what is she what is she doing
what's her career it's psychology okay
what does she want to
do um some sort
of probably social work um something
that you would need a master's degree
most likely okay how old are you guys I
don't think she totally knows yet either
we're I'm 24 she's 23 okay cool I would
recommend that she get a job as a
residence hall director at a university
and move in to a residence hall and they
will pay her housing and they will also
pay her room and board or some degree
they'll give her a salary and they'll
get a significant discount on graduate
school and she wants to be a social
worker or a mental health professional
she will get to live with a room with a
building full of people of all different
places from all different walks of life
with all different types of challenges
and she will learn what case loads are
she'll learn what going to the hospital
is she'll learn what suicidal ideation
she'll learn it all and they'll pay for
it that's what I would recommend if she
was my friend that's what I told her to
do okay Tada do not do not do not borrow
money to go she's going to end up in six
figures of debt Austin not knowing what
she wants to do possibly working at a
job making 45 years Ian the ROI doesn't
make sense and the fact that she doesn't
know what she wants to do I wouldn't go
get a master's
while I'm just buying time and waiting I
would I would go get real life
experience now if she's really serious
about it I would go exact I would do
exactly what John is saying which may
make her very uncomfortable because it's
not an ideal in that scenario right
you're not just living the life you want
and doing whatever you're working you're
you're living you're yeah and you're
working um but Austin too I would be I
would be um not cautious maybe a strong
word don't pay your debt off if you're
not married to her don't yeah no don't
do that and also making sure that she's
aware of why she's $6,000 in credit card
debt and why debt is still an option for
her to go in to as well so there's some
of these things and you may want it more
for her Austin than she wants for
herself so these are conversations you
guys just need to have and be thinking
about but no do not go deeper into debt
for a master's degree on something we
don't know what we want to do and don't
go into debt period so there's some
sacrifices there on a situation you can
do with John laid out and that's what we
would recommend thanks for the
[Music]
call
hey guys it's Rachel Cru it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your health care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian healthc Care
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly $1 billion doll in
healthcare costs chm is an AFF
affordable alternative to insurance that
gives you the freedom and empowers you
to live out your values and you can join
at any time so find out more at
chministries.org
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsay Show
Christmas is gosh it feels like it's
almost here I know we still have
Thanksgiving but it just always feels
like Christmas is just sne so wild all
our decorations are up in Cruise
houseold oh yeah I love it the Delon
like to focus on gratitude for a minute
oh that's nice unlike you guys un like
you don't want joy oh here we go and
peace wow wow no we like to just say
thank you to the world before we just
like give me give me give me Jingle
Bells do you like Little Drummer Boy the
worst song ever written in the history
of humanity love it yep really oh yeah I
can just see you sitting in front of
your fire just
going no no no no it's not little Dum
boy I like it's um who Let The Dogs Out
nope it's the same one the little boy
there's um oh shoot a little boy oh do
Can You Hear What I Hear oh s Do You
Hear What I Hear that's what I was
thinking yeah yeah okay speaking song
where the main instruments is a snare
drum it's never gonna work never good
it's never gonna work except at James
Church that's how y'all Roll All right
so go ahead Ramy the Ramsey cash
giveaway is here which means you can buy
as many songs on iTunes as you want if
you win one of our $500 weekly prizes or
the grand prize of $5,000 so you can
enter every single day at Ramsey
solutions.com giveaway so again you guys
we're giving away $500 a month I mean
$500 a week and a grand prize of $5,000
also make sure to do your Christmas
shopping at ramsy solutions.com store
because we have a huge $12 sale going on
this is the books The Total Money
Makeover baby Subs millionaires own your
past and change your future love your
life not theirs own yourself own your
money there's so much there and even the
questions for humans cards uh the
Christmas edition is back it sold out
last year but you can get all these
cards as low as $10 right now so again
any meaningful gift to give this
Christmas gift Christmas gift ideas go
to Ramy solutions.com store and check
out our sale up next we have Lucy oh
over the pond in London England she's in
the Sky with Diamonds what's up Lucy hey
Lucy oh hi be thank you so much for
taking the time to talk to me I am so
glad what time is it over there right
now um it's about 20 to9 okay so it's a
it's an evening listen right now for you
Lucy so glad that you called in how can
we
help um so I initially thought I needed
guidance on money advice I'm going to a
long and tricky
divorce
um um but I think and it has been a long
time trying to get divorced and arguing
and
just yeah it's kind of unraveled me um
but I think what I'm sorry my thr is
like my heart is like my no you're good
you're good you're
good but I think what I they need
guidance with is how to
make have more confidence with decisions
to know that um however the divorce
works out I'll be okay
sure um oh man what I'm so sorry you're
going through this what what what are
the the arguments
about oh gosh the divorce settlement
well everything everything really um but
it's um
he told me he wanted a divorce two years
ago um and we had been been back and
forward for two years um we did go
through and I don't know if you have the
same thing mediation sure yeah it's non
legally binding and we went through the
process and we we came to a decision at
the start of the year we came to a
compromis position and he's like upturn
overturned that now he wants everything
different um
and he's become quite well I've seen a
different side to him you know very
controlling and he's a bully it turns
out so do you have you have an attorney
or a barister do you have somebody
representing you right now I had a
solicitor um I was struggling with il
legal costs
um it was more than my tiom pay um yeah
um and we hadn't we weren't making any
progress so um I basically the advice I
had from my solicor was just like my
lawyer just just you know go to court um
because what I think we're arguing about
the the laws on my side more I don't
know it's mostly his pensions were
having he's really frustrated about it
he's he's been in the military for a
long time and and he has a very good
pension I followed him around I can idot
yeah you gave up you gave up your life
and you made sure yeah his bills were
paid and his clothes were cleaned and
his house was done and so you were you
were
a right you were a co-contributor to
that house AB 15 years my career is in
the you know in the trash of course and
so whenever you ask the question like I
just need to think about the emotional
part of am I going to be okay there's a
math problem there like am I going to be
okay financially will I be able to pay
my bills right and so it's easy for me
to say here all the way on the other
side of the world um in a home right now
that has a stable marriage but I tell my
the the women that I talk to all the
time please if you
can don't let a
loudmouth goofball on the other side let
the court work for you as best as it can
okay you're entitled to that that's the
law of the land and you g like you said
you gave up everything to co-create this
house with him and so a lot of people
will file for divorce thinking oh I can
just pretend that didn't happen and they
imagine their life financially um
socially they imagine their life is the
exact same just you're not in it and
that's just not how that works so I
would implore you to not walk away from
it but to go to court I don't exactly
know the divorce proceedings in your in
your court system in England but um I
would really um hope you would do that
and take care of yourself not just the
exhausted you right now but the you 5
years and 10 years and 20 years from now
okay that's number one number two it is
sural to be sitting in a room with
somebody or in a building especially if
you're in mediation and they're going
back and forth back and forth you you
created a home
together y'all created kids together
y'all held each other as you held your
newborn and suddenly this person's going
to war against you
exactly how it feels exactly and so I
want you to here's how I get through
those moments I know my
limitations and my limitations are this
I can't I don't make rational choices
when I do that by myself when I get
really emotional I don't so I always
have people that walk alongside
me I I I even use this language I
Outsource that that in those moments and
I've got a couple of men that I trust
that walk with me and I say hey is this
a good deal cuz my wife really wants to
buy this house I don't feel good about
it and they'll say John buy the house
and so I trust them or they'll say dude
I love your wife too but don't buy that
house and I trust them and so I would
tell you you have people that you pay
you've got professionals that do this
you got the the court system I would get
one or two girlfriends that you can
trust that you can say everything to all
the scary things you're feeling all that
stuff so your body knows you're not
doing this
alone and it's not going to make the
math problem any easier it's not going
to make the divorce any less surreal but
your body will have a little bit more
peace because it knows you're going
through this thing not by
yourself that makes sense is that fair
do you have that Lucy do you have some
good friends in your life um I do have
some friends they're not local um I do
have like friendly people local but um
do you have a couple of friendly locals
that you could say hey um I want to take
you to coffee or to tea if you're over
if you're over the pond and let's go get
some tea and yeah cup of tea and I need
someone to walk through with me through
a really heavy season would you be
willing to do that for
me um I feel I just feel such a bird and
and so because it's been going on for so
long
um to like be just this emotional wreck
all the time I do I do have a couple of
really good friends um give them you're
not Hey listen listen I'm going to say
this as directly as I can honey you are
not a
let them love
you let them love you mhm and if they
don't want to let them have the
opportunity to say ah I really don't
want to love you like that right
now one of the greatest gifts I one of
the greatest honors I feel and I know
Rachel's the same way is when one
somebody that we care about and love
reaches out and says can you help me
golly dude there are a few honors more
powerful than that but reach out and
talk to somebody and yes I think you got
to go to court you've been messing
around on the edges with this for two
years you've been trying to do the right
thing and he has proven that he is not
interested in doing the right thing he's
interested in beating you defeating you
we're done with that we're going to get
the courts involved so we can get this
thing settled and moved on you're not a
burden my
friend
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsy show I am
Rachel Cruz hosting this hour with Dr
John delone so it's a free call anywhere
in the country at Triple 8 825 5225 up
next we have Albert in San Antonio Texas
hey Albert welcome to the
show thank you thank you for having me
absolutely how can we help yes uh my
wife retired this last year and I'm
probably going to return about another
year and we have about 1.3 1.4 million
in in Investments nice hey Albert can
you be a huge favor can you speak right
into your phone for me yes is that
better much better yeah thank you
okay yes my name is my wife retired last
year and I'm going to retired about a
year we have about one 1.3 in
Investments were debt free including the
house
amazing yeah so but uh we kind of Boral
we had a car payments up till about two
years ago two car payments but we
probably we just D it and paid off the
all our that's the only we we Lo is the
cars at the house so we got rid of that
in the last two years but um we're
talking to a financial advisor right now
to see what's best we want to we have
most of it in okay and some of it in the
new and some of in stock but he's she's
thinking about just taking all of it and
just put it on a rout R and just giveing
him the full amount I was wondering if
that's like a safe idea or is that a
good idea or should I be more DET first
right do you guys do you guys have a
Roth already or just the
401K Just 4 mostly one we're thinking
about putting it all to a Roth switching
it all to the
WTH um what would the tax implications
be did they tell
you well tell us say we're going to put
it on we don't have to pay the taxes
because we pull it out of the 4K and
just put it on back at our rout and roll
it to the WTH right but when you
withdraw though and you move it to the
Roth usually if it's not a traditional
IRA there's G to be taxes that's
paid well they usually charge a fee uh I
know they charge a people but since
we're here to more a million they're
waving the fee they didn't say that we
have to pay the taxes okay
okay uh this is a lot of money Albert
and so this is why I'm just cautious of
just giving you a two-minute radio
answer because this is your this is y''s
retirement that you're that you're
talking about here uh how did you find
your financial adviser I'm just
curious uh just it's the same person
that the few other people that work used
they they've been as each they've been
using this one person it's it's a b it's
a large Bank here's what I don't like
about it um and I'll would tell you when
you when you're talking about
diversification I can't tell if there
there's one question that is should I
move all of this and begin to do a back
door Roth and roll it that way that's
one question the other question was
you've got an annuity over here and some
stocks over here I would do my best to
get out of those so that isn't the
diversification I'm looking for the
diversification would come inside of
your retirement funds right so here that
that those are two different questions
here's my underlying problem with the
person you've picked there they're
treating you like you're dumb and
they're saying just give me all of your
money I'll take care of it and the
reason I don't like that is a I'm not
dumb I just don't know about this
particular thing and B I want someone
with the heart of a teacher who if
they're going to move something or do
something they're going to explain why
so my financial adviser will call me and
say Hey I want to recommend that we move
this particular fund over to this fund
and here's why and here's the impact on
you it's your money it's your call I'll
support whatever you want to do that's
different than ah just give it to me
I'll handle
it they they kind of explained it to me
that they're going to rest and it's
going to be in so many you know the
whatever they this they show me this is
what we to put your money at we would
put it in 50% here 50% here you know
yeah but did they tell you different
mutual
funds was it mutual
funds I don't think mutal funds was one
of them okay so so what we recommend
when it comes to retirement specifically
are four types of mutual funds so
there's internet a growth aggressive
growth growth in income and
international so what John's saying is
right that with inside of that WTH
inside the 401K that you have the way
that your money's divided up is
diversifying within different types of
mutual funds and so that's what we teach
at Ramsay so that's why I almost would
just recommend Albert that you if you
hang on the line Austin will pick up and
help get you in contact with one of our
smart Vestor Pros because I would just
want a second opinion on all of this
because I something doesn't smell right
well and yeah and you guys then at that
point would have to do a yeah it would
have to pay back to a Roth because of
the amount because you guys don't
qualify for a traditional Roth IRA I
don't know if they want to do
traditional and then I mean like I yeah
I I honestly Albert I just feel
comfortable you sitting down with
somebody getting a second opinion
because if they're asking for all of
this money I just want to make sure that
I have two to three to four options that
then you and your wife can sit down and
look versus just going to this one guy
because two other friends you know went
to him so these are big decisions and
again the tax implications and all of
this is really big too what you pull out
what you roll things over to now if you
roll it over to a traditional IRA at
that point we do tell people to do that
when they leave their jobs to move their
401K over I mean there's different
things like that that the tax yeah but
again I would just double double check
on all of that because I don't want you
hit with a huge tax bill not expecting
it and by the way just so people
listening know Rachel us a smart vistor
Pro I use Smart Vester Pro Dave like
this is just what we do with our our
family's money and so it's not like it's
a we all Drive Hondas and we're telling
you to drive a Toyota this is what we do
with our money too absolutely absolutely
thanks for the call Albert up next we
have antoinet in Sacramento California
welcome to the show Hello thank you so
much for calling how can we
help um I me and my husband are at the
end of paying off the remaining of our
debt and I just kind of want some advice
on how to move forward because we have
four homes and we're kind of uh we
friendly banter about which home should
we pay off first which way should we
moved and so I just kind of wanted some
advice on what what you guys think are
these like homes that you guys just live
in are they rentals what what are they
so I we have one primary home and three
rentals and three rentals okay um okay
how much is owed on the three
rentals okay so on um the first friend
well I mean gu doesn't matter so on my
husband came to the marriage we got
married three two years ago so we just
combined we just got together a year ago
and we combinded all of our stuff this
is why we're going back and forth about
the homes aw so on my home on my home
that I came into the marriage with um I
have
296,000 left on it and that's here in
California okay how much would that be
worth
now yes uh so my home currently is worth
631 th000 whoa nice okay yeah um on his
home in North Carolina he has one that's
worth 100 or sorry that he owes or we
owe 198,000 on and um that home
currently is worth uh 298,000 okay and
then on the second on the third home in
North Carolina also we owe 135,000 on
that one and that home is currently
worth 282,000
282 okay um where yall living are y'all
in Sacramento we're living in C yes yes
and is that where your house is the
first one that you're talking about that
is where yes and then the home that we
bought last year that we're living in
right now is also here okay perfect okay
um I could probably tell you what I
would
do I would sell both in North Carolina
uh I don't want to be can I tell you the
ties first we have three children I have
one child he has two children and both
of us like I bought my home to for my
son for for him later and he bought his
two homes one for each of his daughters
so that's kind of where our emotional
ties are like we really don't want to
sell our homes no but you can't afford
them we can't afford them no you took
you didn't buy them you took out
mortgages on them you wrote a note so
the bank would give do what the renters
are paying for it in his
entirety I here's none of our money goes
into the home I'm sorry go ahead you
have a chance to be start this new
marriage completely free mhm no house
payment no payments to anybody in the
world no stress let me ask you this
would y'all just decide to buy a rental
property in Maryland and and manage it
that
way no and are your kids gonna be moving
to North
Carolina his two daughters are in North
they do live in North Carolina and my
son lives in California with us are they
staying in those
homes when they get older probably okay
see here's here can I tell you hey okay
yeah oh shoot we're out of time okay
here's here's the thing your heart in it
is so good Inn it but the way that it's
being progressed you're putting these
expectations on your kids that they're
going to want this home versus saying
hey we're we have $200,000 to help you
with your down payment or whatever
whatever instead of a house we actually
have cash to help you maybe you look
into something like that versus forcing
these homes on them that you guys to
John's Point are continuing to be
longdistance landlords in and it's not I
I don't like it so I would sell the two
in North Carolina I'd pay off the one in
California you guys ride off ride off
into the sunset with some great money
and houses and figure out how to help
your kids after that this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I am bestselling author
and Ramsey personality Rachel Cruz
hosting this hour with bestelling author
Ramsey person Dr John delone that's
actually how you introduce to people in
restaurants I do feel weird that I said
bestselling I introduced myself that way
sorry America sorry America I could have
just said Ram's personality Rachel Cruz
I'm bestselling author Rachel can I see
your drink menu please well mix that
from the next intro but we're glad that
you are here it's a free call anywhere
in the country at
225 all right let's go to the phones we
got Howard in Indianapolis Hey Howard
welcome to the
show hey Rachel hey John happy early
Thanksgiving there absolutely Rachel
doesn't celebrate it she goes straight
to Christmas but I accept it because
Howard do you have Christmas decorations
up no but my wife is kind of wanting us
to do that soon pushing the way I feel
you I feel her double down on gratitude
man so great how can we help yeah I
won't hold you long um so I did the
crazy thing I did bethl Tech uh last
year graduated in May of this year um I
will be starting at Salesforce next week
good for you so I doubled my income and
I will be replacing some of my wife's
income dude that's awesome thank you
thank you so I'm happy U we'll have a
100K household income but of the caveat
um we are expecting um January due date
oh congratulations you got a lot of
change coming in that house I know a lot
of change yes that's a lot so um the
question is uh I'm familiar with the
baby steps but do we pause that on stack
cash
for um the baby cuz one paycheck
realistically could take care of all our
expenses um that you know of yeah yes uh
do you guys do you guys have any money
saved uh this the1 th000 uh baby step F
how much how much debt do you guys have
uh we have right under 65k okay yeah so
you would be on baby step two and we do
say to pause that specific baby step if
you are in baby steps four five and six
you could kind of keep going and you
know keep some money on the side but as
you're paying off debt uh that is a
place that we would say to pause While
You're Expecting which is just another 3
months I mean you guys will be having
the baby soon but I would yes Save um
some money aside till baby comes and
Mom's home and baby's home and all is
good and then from there then you can
throw the rest of that money that you
guys have saved in these three months at
the debt uh and continue on so pay
minimums pay minimum stack stack cash
all the extra money exactly yes stay
current on everything don't get behind
uh so pay those minimum payments and
then uh yeah save up that cash and
hopefully you were able to throw some
great cash at the 65 and continue down
um and paying off debt think we should
be able to pay it off within a year and
a half um good for you Howard I'm so
proud of you of of do of making a change
I feel like even as an adult it's hard
for people to think through oh my gosh
how could I do something to up my income
even change careers doing something
completely new and I mean it's a it's a
real success story of of how you did it
with bethl Tech which is awesome uh and
having a degree and going to Salesforce
and doubling your income and I mean all
of it it's just incredible and whatever
spreadsheet you've cranked out for how
much your life is going to change
financially now that you have a kid I
can just tell you you're off probably by
a factor of
100 I thought a kid would like a baby a
newborn would just go to the bathroom
once or twice or three times a day like
a normal person and they don't they go
thousand times a day 1,000 times so you
probably have like I got 60 bucks a
month for diapers that's half that's
that'll get you from 8:00 a.m. to noon
on day one right so there's going to be
expenses like that that man and heaven
forbid anything happens during the
delivery that they gotta you know do an
extra this or do another that or
something so yeah just having cash is
good man yeah that's great
congratulations Howard sooud stack that
cash away and then yep press play on the
Deb snowball once baby and mom are home
right up next we have Katherine in St
Paul hey Katherine welcome to the
show hi thank you so much for taking my
call absolutely how can we
help um so my husband and I recently
became debt-free and we thank you
congratulations and we have a fully
funded emergency fund and we're saving
it for a
house um my question is we're planning a
two week vacation to Italy hopefully
this summer and my husband just wants to
kind of let go of a financial thought
for a little bit of it and just let's
spend what we spend and have fun and I'm
wondering what is too much to spend oh
you called the two right people cuz I'm
kind of a KOA guy I love the KOA and
Rachel vacations differently than me
this is going to be fantastic my gosh uh
okay Catherine how much do you guys make
a
year we make just a little over 80 take
home okay okay and after expenses and
stuff I mean how much have you guys
saved for it so
far well or you're starting that process
now idea okay so we just started that
process now we have about
30 38 set aside because we're trying to
save up for a house within the next two
years and and then a fully funded
emergency fund and 15% to retirement and
all of that yeah um do you guys have a
house right now or you looking to
upgrade or buy buy your first home buy
first home okay so yeah so saving up
that down payment how much you guys
wanting for the down
payment oh 20% minimum it's not more
which would be what for you guys as
you're looking at different houses and
stuff um I imagine about 50 to 60 okay
okay
um yeah so you guys probably won't have
that for another few years is that
right um I would since we're at about 30
uh my husband's income should shoot up
he's graduating school soon and oh good
okay yeah I imagine hopefully hopefully
sooner than that okay because the 38 is
that just for your emergency fund or you
is that some of that for the down
payment no that's house that's that's
house oh oh I'm sorry that's just house
so you guys have a separate emergency
fund oh I got you okay perfect yeah um I
mean I always hesitate to give specific
like dollar amounts or percentages when
it comes to something like vacation or a
car because it really is you don't want
to go extreme either way right because
you guys have done the hard work you've
paid off you you're saving up a great
down payment um so yeah I mean I gosh I
mean two weeks in Italy can it's I mean
that's a long time the length of time is
long you guys picked a pretty you know
just an expensive destination how much
do you think that's going to cost
um I my husband was like oh let's just
cap it make sure we don't spend more
than 10K and I was about to say 10K in
my head I was like it's probably going
to cost that I think it'll cost you that
to get over there for two weeks in
Italy oh and I should say um my
husband's uh military so housing is like
or sorry hotels are going to be like
next to nothing okay um so that makes a
big dent yeah I mean I don't lose sleep
over 10,000 bucks if you have that in
cash I don't see how any way you could
get that done in Italy for 2 weeks with
10,000 but maybe that's just me yeah I
mean I think that that cap sounds right
to me with what you guys have what
you're making what you have saved and
all of that that feels good but I hope
you can do it I think you can you think
so yeah I think you can do that I just
don't want to go to Italy and eat Arby's
like I want to go to Italy and like like
do it right eat a lot of gelato I'd have
a cap though Katherine I think it's
smart of what he said this is the Ramy
show
[Music]
I
welcome back to the ramsy show we are
taking your calls it's a free call
anywhere in the country at 8825
5225 and if you enjoy the ramsy show if
you wouldn't mind subscribing leaving a
review sharing it with your friends
getting the word out to anyone and
everyone is always helpful uh when it
comes to spreading this message and you
guys do that a lot for us so we very
much are grateful and appreciate that
but we love your feedback with the
reviews again we love you uh spreading
the love and sharing some of these
episodes with your friends and your
family all right up next we have Donald
in New York City hey Donald welcome to
the
show hey guys thanks for taking my call
my first time long time oh so glad you
called in how can we
help all right so I'm GNA give you my
sort of well I'll give you my financial
situation but uh I recently had
something coming about with with our
work today so I got one of those Dre
emails inviting me to you know come on
call and stuff like that and you
know I'm assuming it's the worst going
for for the te leaves of my company that
they are doing layoffs right now so
nothing said St right now but I am
preparing for the rest on my end
okay so you got an email let make sure I
said you right you got an email from
your company that you have to come in
for a meeting
pretty much I'm sorry
what yeah pretty much that there was it
was with uh two people that I
technically work above okay kind of
company structures work really that that
way where I have multiple different
managers and stuff like that okay so
you're thinking that you're thinking the
worst yeah know you're good you're
thinking the worst that you're probably
gonna be laid
off right exactly okay okay um you don't
know but sure sure it may not be but
that's what you're thinking my mind goes
there Dave if Dave might give me a
promotion might make a new might make a
new partner 23 years old hey if Dave
texts me at 4:00 and he's like hey run
by my office I'm always like oh great
this is it right so I'm with you that
happens to me too all right so um how
can we help what's your question yeah uh
let's see here in ter in terms of my
financial pre preparations assuming
worst case scenario I mean in terms of
my performance at this job right now I'm
not sure if I if I necessarily like it
that much I work at a public accounting
company so so that side of things is
Dreadful in terms of workload and stuff
like that so there could be a potential
shift then like the next one or two
years but but in terms of like but that
process could be accelerated as soon as
tomorrow so I was wondering in terms of
my financials right now I'm currently on
baby step three and four okay in terms
of my S savings I was wondering how
should I go about this process because I
do want to move because I am open to
relocating of course you know New York
is a very high cost of the living area
you get tax death for sure yep um okay
so you how much money do you have
saved uh right now and non-retirement
accounts I got $40,000 saved good for
you okay yeah thank you you and you
don't have a big Runway dude they're
gonna like they're gonna tell you
tomorrow right yeah when's the
meeting uh tomorrow sorry you have no
Runway it's not like in three months
I've got this yeah yeah yeah so I mean I
think right now you just wait for the
meeting Donald and if they lay you off
which like you said you don't even know
so let's say they do lay you off I don't
know if it's immediate termination or
whatever you get so then I would just
have to you I would use my emergency
fund to float through my expenses while
I look for a new job that's why it's
there which is perfect we use job loss
all the time as an example sadly for
that's why you have an emergency fund so
you have 40 Grand saved which is amazing
and then you may look yeah for another
job um hopefully get one in the next 30
60 days 90 days and then start back and
replenish the emergency fund and then
start retirement investing from there
but if they don't lay you off you're
saying that you may not even enjoy the
job completely is that right that's
right okay so yeah so if that's the case
then maybe you're looking for a career
shift in a little bit but you are you're
23 is this is this your first full-time
job my first job ask yes yeah um yeah so
I mean there's maybe a level too with
accounting that you pay your dues and
you got do the grunt work first right
before you're going to be promoted and
do the thing you really want to do I
mean there's a reality to that to work
um but also you don't want to hate your
job and all of that either so I think
that there's a balance there and
understanding you're going to have to do
things in your job that you don't enjoy
but also you want to make sure you're in
an industry and around people that you
you know you enjoy the company and you
enjoy what you do you work a lot of
hours of your life there and so um Ken
Coleman one of our Ram person's um he
does a great job when it comes to
talking about your purpose and he has an
assessment why am I blinking on the name
of the assessment this is It's career
assessment the career assessment is that
what it's called the career assessment
okay I was going to say it's about your
career um so if you hold on the line uh
Donald Austin's oh yeah the get clear
assessment that's what it is um Austin's
going to pick up and I want to give you
um an access code to that to take for
free because I think that could give you
maybe even some other dire
and to kind of see what your skills are
what you enjoy your passions CU I think
the earlier you find that and things
will shift in your life but the earlier
you can find some direction uh and
encouragement and maybe it's just
confirmation that it is accounting and
that you're in the right spot and you
may just be looking for a different firm
to work for or whatnot but as far as the
job loss goes I wouldn't panic because
it hasn't happened but if it happens
it's going to happen hopefully you'll
get some Severance and you look for a
new job and that that's how the world
yeah goes around that's what happens
let's let's think through this though
practically for people listening who who
are going to find themselves in the
situation and unfortunately we're in Q4
and companies want to make their end of
your numbers so they just lay off a
bunch of people so they can wave their
magic papers in front of Wall Street and
say look how great we're doing so you
have get an email and or a text message
or something or hey we need to meet with
you tomorrow and you know the company's
doing layoffs immediately your body goes
to fight or flight as it should if it
doesn't you probably need to go see
somebody ASAP so feel it put your hand
in your chest and feel your body trying
to take care of you and then the next
thing get a yellow pad a a a a Word
document a spreadsheet whatever you want
to do and literally type up a make a
column what can I control right now and
what can I not
control you're going to find real quick
that you can control what you have for
dinner you can control if you go on a
drinking binge or not you can control if
hey I'm I know this is coming I'm going
to go ahead and send out three I'm just
going to send out three applications
right now just to get them out I can
control that I can go hang out with my
friends what you can't control is
whether they fire you tomorrow you can't
control you can control the time you go
to bed even if you lay there all night
and toss and turn and so there's
something powerful about all right this
is what I can do that's it and I'm not
going to spiral and spiral and spiral
and by the way if you don't have $40,000
it's going to be a long long long night
it just is because your body's going to
know that it's fate is decided tomorrow
and what you'll find tomorrow is the sun
will come up and you get some difficult
challenging news if they lay you off and
you're going to be heartbroken and
devastated and all
that then the sun's going to come up the
next day then you have a choice to make
am I going to make a my full-time job
getting a new job or am I going to just
sit here and be upset and be up so what
can I control what can I not let's call
some friends and let's see what happens
tomorrow hey I do I am interested about
this um so Donald do send us a note and
let us know um if you made the cut or if
you're going to be looking for a new job
yeah for sure because there is a reality
to that right I don't want to downplay
what happened but also there you know
I've learned cuz this can be me I can
take a scenario and I go to the in
degree and I play the story in my head I
get anxious I all the things and it
wasn't even a reality like it wasn't
even what I that literally happened a
few weeks ago Dave was like hey I need
to talk to you at you didn't think you
were getting fired John I know you worry
about that a lot but here's we worry
about John sometimes my body went to
this has to be bad right right my
default is I start cranking up imaginary
stories yes if he says this I'm going to
and I just start going down the road and
it was literally I was driving and I
started laughing out loud yeah and by
the way this is 10 years of me working
on this so it's not just an overnight
fix but I started laughing and I said
out loud nothing you're doing is going
to help that meeting right yeah and then
I texted three people two of which
responded oh this has nothing to do with
you it has something to do with
something else and it was ah well could
I control I could ask hey does anybody
know what this meeting is about yeah for
sure it's not you help me out yeah it
was all good totally yes yes and then I
went on about my day I know so yes so
sometimes hard things do happen in these
meetings and you got to face the reality
just like what John was explaining
earlier which I think is great and then
sometimes you guys we're all crazy
people in our heads and you create
stories of reality that is not even
reality and we sit there and twist and
turn and freak out and it's not even a
thing so also have that dose in the back
of your head it's that Balancing Act but
thank you Donald for the call this is
the Ramy
show
[Music]
so one part about winning with money
that is super crucial to having a plan
and having some tactical things in place
is a budget and our every dollar app is
the best on the planet when it comes to
budgeting it's the one I use and my
husband Winston we share uh an account
there and we track I track transactions
this afternoon before the show and we
keep up really with every single thing
we just were on a trip in New York and
we were getting our transactions from
New York and I have a New York line item
in our budget this month and we just
drop it into that category and it's just
helpful to know what is going on so if
you've not checked out every dollar make
sure to go to Every doll.com check out
that app too there's a free version you
can download in the App Store but also
we have an every dooll webinar at if you
go to every doll / budgeting Jade
warshaw myself and George Campell have
been doing separate webinars walking you
guys through how to budget the
importance of it this topic in general
and then walking you through some of the
every doll features every dollar premium
because it has paycheck planning Bank
connectivity a bunch of different stuff
to really help you get this in a process
and in a habit in your life uh when it
comes to budgeting so again go to
everydollar.com
budgeting to check that out I think I
have a webinar coming up I think on the
20th I think next week I'll be doing one
um so make sure to sign up and join us
there all right up next we have faith in
Louisville Louis Louisville Louisville
because you got to have faith the faith
we're gonna say Louisville Faith welcome
to the show Louisville Lille we got it
we got it love it so my husband and I
just started the debt snowball and I'm a
teacher and he works for Kentucky fish
and wildlife and um in the de snowball
you know student loans are supposed to
be included but ours will be forgiven in
seven years through Public service loan
forgiveness so I was curious if we com
if we use that as part of the debt
snowball or if we just continued paying
the minimum payments until we reach
seven years who's going to be the
president in seven
years only my God
no yeah I wouldn't trust the government
on anything when it comes to the subject
faith I think it's guys that will paying
your student loans off I had I I I was I
was a Dena student at a law school and I
had some of the most brilliant young
minds who for did not go into um private
law practice to where they could make a
jillion dollars because they wanted to
serve their communities and because the
government said they would pay their
loans off after 10 years of public
service and for many many many of them
that did not happen so I have a
follow-up question then okay so we have
a we have a pretty good savings right
now and we have about 5,000 in savings
and that could pay a lot of one of our
credit cards off and um so me and my
husband are just so scared to let go of
that 4,000 as part of the debt snowball
um but I think I know that answered your
question is I think I know what you all
are going to say is put 4,000 towards
debt keep a th you got to have faith a
faith of faith faith my gosh Fai what
what all are your what what's all your
debt you have how much in credit card
debt so we have um 92,000 total in debt
okay 68 of that is student loans between
me and my husband that's ours okay and
then um 18 of that is our vehicle
payment we only have one vehicle payment
and then um 1,400 is medical debt okay
and then 5,000 is credit card debt
okay um what what caused the credit card
debt just lifestyle uh College okay yeah
how much you guys make I worked at uh we
make about 6,200 a month after taxes
okay
um okay
so you guys have
kids yes we have a threey old okay
sweet um yeah Faith you got a lot you
got a lot to tackle here and I know you
know that because you're you're aware um
and it will scare you yes of going down
but I would I would pay that medical
debt off today go ahead and knock that
out I mean it's it was $1,400 right is
what you said correct yep I would I
would just get that out of the way
because what that's going to do is gonna
be like oh okay we got there's one
there's one gone there's one gone it's
it's this kind of mind game that you're
going to play with yourself with this
dead snowball that actually works this
is what creates the behavior change
because I need you guys to have some
quick wins you guys are kind of new to
this process I'm so thankful that you're
actually facing this headon and tackling
this stuff um but I want you to feel
that quick win so I do I want you to pay
that off yeah and then Faith you're
exactly right I am going to tell you to
put the rest to start knocking out this
credit card debt this $5,000 will be the
next one that you're tackling um and
that sense of urgency because the $1,000
it's really not meant to be there to be
enough for everything okay and we have
this safety net that we want to feel
which understand that's why we put a
large emergency fund after paying off
debt so it's going to feel uncomfortable
you're not supposed to say oh my gosh
$1,000 is fine now some people they
don't have even that and they're having
to save that for their first steps you
guys at least have that and that's for
all the ankle biter stuff but then if
something big happens then you're going
to pause the de snowball save up money
for if the heating in air goes out I
mean something insane but usually stuff
is not do right away if it's a big
emergency so you're going to pause it at
snowball if something comes up that you
need more cash for
you're going to save for that and then
you're going to press play back on the
de snowball and continue this process
but yes I would recommend going down to
$1,000 and then faith for a season
because of what you guys make
considering your debt it's going to be
hard to make a dent in this
92,000 again considering you guys
probably bring you know it's probably a
$72,000 combined income so you guys need
to get your incomes up you really need
to so I don't know if that's through
side hustles I don't know if that's
looking at a job change but um I know
it's a big ask in your season with a
three-year-old but you guys got to
figure out something for a season to get
that income up because it's it's going
to it's going to be a longer process if
you don't just because of your numbers
so um yeah I hope that helps I know it's
it can feel deflating sometimes when
you're looking at numbers like that but
you guys you got to and you're a teacher
which I thank you so much I mean so so
thankful for for you and your work um
but I don't know if there's
tutoring on the side you can do I don't
know if your husband looks at a at a job
change for a season a period of time or
just bringing on that extra income but
something something needs to be upped
there because even your expenses I don't
think there's probably a ton of expenses
to cut um I mean Louisville thankfully
is not New York City or Miami or
something like that where the standard
of living is that much higher um but
still it's expensive life is you know
life is expensive I get that so where
you can cut expenses I would do that but
if you hold on the line Austin's going
to pick up and I want to give you guys
Financial Peace University this is our
nine lesson course and I would love for
you and your husband to sit down and
watch these lessons and really buckle
down because I think what it'll do it'll
affirm what you're already feeling about
this change and what you want to do
maybe you'll learn some new stuff that's
also a hope um that's in there but that
again to solidify you guys in this
process because it's not going to be
easy it's it's going to be a marathon
and if he's allowed to um give your
husband's info to Austin on the line and
if he can do a guided hunt and fishing
for me and my son I I love to hire him
cuz I'll just drive up to Kentucky that
would be a blast so I'll hook him up
that would be his side hustle I don't if
he's allowed if game's allowed to do
that but that'd be fantastic be so
perfect so perfect oh well thanks Faith
thanks for calling yeah I think that
this is this is where the tough reality
meets the road when it comes to your
money you guys is that when you you know
especially when you look at numbers like
theirs like they're a great example this
is this is what a lot of people are
facing where you basically have more
debt than you have income um and can
feel very overwhelming and that's where
a plan and and and a timeline for me
John always says it but it's true facts
are your friends and so as much facts as
you can get around this because your
emotions possibly may be all over the
map but if you can do a timeline and say
okay we got to back out what do we have
to do to be out of debt in four years
what are the things we have to do how
many hours extra do we have to work a
week like you start putting actual an
actual plan around this so it's not this
idea floating around in your head cuz
sometimes for me that's where the fear
can start to magnify if it's just this
idea and it sounds so scary and I'm
looking at numbers I'm like oh my gosh
how's this going to happen but as
detailed as a plan faith that you can do
I think I think is key and it's also
important that we we kind of blow over
this sometimes you and your husband I
want yall to spend a weekend like just
being sad because you have a
three-year-old and he's doing Public
Service you're doing Public Service the
idea is y'all went to college you do
what you told your public servants y are
helping out your community you should be
able to have a house MH and a car two
cars and you found yourself in a hole
and so be sad for a weekend we wanted
this to look like this and it's not
going to right now we're going to have
to do a ton of hard hard work but those
days will come if you put your foot on
the gas you got
[Music]
this
our scripture of the day comes from
james4 let perseverance finish its work
so that you may be mature and complete
not lacking in
anything and Maya Angelo says nothing
will work unless you do also a great
quote nothing will work unless you do
you got to do
it which is amazing I feel like
sometimes we want like a magic fairy to
come in and just fix it all be healthy
emotionally get a raise at work work do
all the things for
us doesn't always happen we sometimes
have to put in that work yeah I I was it
um horos the other day said Alex said uh
your success is found in the work you
are avoiding like just start doing it y
just start doing it that's right that's
right so so good all right up next we
have Kylie in Minneapolis hey Kylie
welcome to the
show hi hello how can we
help um so I recently just started a new
job um I'm not making too much money
just about I think I'm making 1350 okay
um I started two weeks ago and I was you
know kind of searching for other jobs
too and I got another job offer that
offered me
$18 okay um the thing is is that my
boyfriend is completely unsupportive
about me moving to this other
job um so I'm kind of torn between
staying at this job um making him happy
versus going to this other job and
causing some conflict in our
relationship um okay how pretty what are
you doing now for a
job um I'm currently at Fleet Farm I
just do stocking okay and what's the new
job it would be in a factory um doing
Peete prep okay and why is he
unsupportive of
that um he is I think he has a lot of
history of other people cheating on him
this new job would be working mainly
with not men um so I think he's kind of
an insecurity things okay how old are
you
guys uh I'm 20 he's 19 okay how long
have you guys been
dating about eight months okay do you
think
um anything hidden to the
official conversation like do you think
that is he it or are you guys just
dating I what was that do you think that
he's is he your husband do you think
like okay yeah he's probably who I'm
going to end up with or do you think no
we're just dating and we're going to see
what
happens um no we've done a lot of
talking that's the end goal is to
obviously get married you know once
we're in a good place okay so the fact
that it's that serious in a relationship
Kylie does raise a lot of red flags for
me in his insecurity I mean if he's been
cheated John's the relationship expert
I'm let him jump in on most of this but
I'm like dying man if he's If he if he's
you go you go why am I go John no go
ahead go ahead well what I was gonna say
is yeah I mean I I mean I understand
that he's like oh man I don't want this
to happen again because what I went
through sucks and it hurts but all that
fact that he's putting all of that on
you and it's completely out of jealousy
and insecurity Kylie that's a red that's
that's a problem there are more red
flags here than at the red flag Factory
like where they make red
flags yeah dude I I I mean think about
what he's telling you hey I don't want
you to improve your life
financially because I um will be
uncomfortable H right so I'm going to
attach my lack of trust and my lack of
belief in myself and my La lack of own
personal security
I'm going to make you carry that around
to the tune of $5 an
hour that's how little I think of you
and your
trustworthiness okay if you were my
sister I would um tell you to listen to
what the great Jay-Z says and that is to
brush your shoulders off and roll and
here's the problem Kylie so sweeping it
under the rug isn't going to fix it so
what does that mean when you actually
present him that no this is a better job
for me and and I I'm I'm going to move
forward how he responds to that Kylie
says a lot about who he is okay okay and
as yeah we're gonna we're gonna be your
big siblings we're gonna I'm GNA be your
big sister John I'll be your big brother
in this I think that that's and and why
I asked how serious the relationship is
because I'm like I just want you to be
very aware and go in to I don't want you
to make a decision a lifelong decision
of something like
marriage when there's conversations like
this happening does that make
sense yeah yep absolutely and by the way
he's 18 how many people have cheated on
him between 14 and 18 good
grief no I mean I guess he's had two
girlfriends um before me and they both
cheated on him with the same guy
so dude yeah now you could make this
super interesting if that guy works at
the factory please tell me that's true
right does he no no not at all we live
about an hour and a half away from me I
was going to start chanting Cherry
Cherry that would have been awesome that
would have been awesome but listen um if
he had the courage let me let me try to
see both sides of this if he had the
courage to tell you hey I've been
cheated on twice and the fact that
you're going to be working you're going
to be the only woman on the floor at
this Factory and guys are going to be
like treating you like crap they're
going to be cat calling they're going to
be they're they're just going to be all
like I know how those dudes are makes me
super uncomfortable I want to say good
for him for speaking that out loud that
needs to be followed with but I trust
you and if you tell me you can't do this
$18 an hour job even though it's it
would be amazing for you and eventually
when we get married me too um and you
say I can't be around these people I'll
I'll I'll be right there to help you get
your stuff out of there and if you tell
me no this is this is incredible I'm
learning some great stuff I've got a
I've got a leadership track here I'm
going to start $18 an hour I'm going to
stay on I'll be at $25 an hour in a year
and have awesome but you see like
vulnerability is part of it and so is
trust and you got to have both of those
things right yeah yeah I think that's
you know he did Express though it's
basically how you did and it's just
really the trust part so but listen
Rachel and I we just talked to a lot of
couples and here's what happens if you
don't if if you don't attune to that red
flag this next is you have a you get
pregnant and he says yeah um the mother
of my kid doesn't do X Y and Z and to
make him happy I'll just listen and do
it which that gets so dangerous so fast
who you are Kylie like on your end so
learning to work through this could be
either an eye opening moment for you
Kylie to be like this doesn't feel great
anymore I don't know how I feel about
this or you push in and it's a great
moment of saying okay this is some
conflict and he's telling me this stuff
and I'm speaking up and we're actually
going to work through this problem
together and it actually strengthens you
guys and you guys become healthier but
don't please don't just sweep it under
the rug and do it because it's it's good
for him and this is what he wants it's
not it's not going to be healthy it
doesn't turn into anything healthy
healthy for you or healthy for your
relationship or possible future marriage
like nothing good comes out of that
Kylie
okay okay so how would I I mean you know
that I kind of looked at the place um I
really haven't mentioned that I I wanted
to wait because we live so far away to
from each other to talk him in person
rather than over text or over the phone
oh y even y even in the same
community no he lives about an hour and
a half
away playing boyfriend and girlfriend on
the
internet we see each other every weekend
for about four days so oh well don't I
wouldn't change my career around him let
me just say that you go Kylie you go do
what you need to do and how he responds
is going to to say a lot about who he is
and who you're going to decide to be in
a relationship with look in the eye and
say I won't cheat on you and just know
you guys are 19 and 20 and I never want
to like be aitt people because of their
age but also know like you guys are
figuring out life and this is a really
good moment for you Kylie to start
practicing what it looks like for what
Kylie needs and what does Kylie need
Kylie needs a freaking $5 hour raise
it's huge it's huge great humongous and
Kye needs to learn that it's not your
job to make sure everybody else in the
world that their needs get taken care of
before yours okay you have to be able to
say here's what I need and right now
you're looking at like I need groceries
and so I'm going to meet that need and
look him in the eyes I won't you and
you're doing nothing wrong by taking
this job either like if you were doing
something immoral sure but there's
nothing immoral about this you're doing
great and God help you don't cheat on
him with that other guy cuz that just
that's going to be a whole different
phone call if you that well yeah for his
sake Insanity don't do that all right
well thanks John uh for another great
hour thank you America for listening
thanks all the guys in the booth this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
a